thanks for convening a short notice I
can't believe
it but here we are this Atomic
test the Russians have a bomb we're
supposed to be years ahead of them
but what were you guys doing in Los
Alamos and how many people were in these
uh open discussions too many
compartmentalization was supposed to be
the protocol We R in the race against
the
Nazis so now the race is against the
Soviets not unless we started Robert
they just fired starting
[Music]
gun what's the nature of the device they
detonated data indicates it may have
been a plutonium implosion device like
the one you built at Los
Alamos a secret
laboratory the middle of nowhere keep
everyone there until it's done why if we
don't let scientists bring their
families we'll never get the best build
him a town why would I leave my family I
told you you can bring your family I'm
not a soldier Obby a soldier he's a
general I've got all the soldier I need
what can I tell them as much as you like
until you feel my boot on your balls you
know Isotopes and you know explosives
you can't tell us what you're
doing why would we go to the middle of
nowhere for who knows how long for a
year or two or three it's about
unleashing the strong
force
before the Nazis do oh my God how about
because this is the most important thing
to ever happen in the history of the
world here you got a little town
everybody will go
[Music]
crazy they won't let me leave I won't
let you leave
[Music]
what happening isn't
it I don't know if we can be trusted
with such a weapon but I know the Nazis
can you can convince anyone of
anything in yourself it was dead with a
Japanese fight
hon nobody knows what you believe do you
there were rumors of Espionage
unsubstantiated Los there's no proof
there was a spy at Los
[Music]
Alamos you felt you judgment was sound
on who on the team could be trusted no
one is leaving Los Alamos what are you
doing
[Music]
well we had a moment where it looked
like the chain reaction from an atomic
device might never stop are we saying
there's a chance that when we push that
button we destroy the world chances are
near zero near zero what do you want
from Theory alone
zero would be
[Music]
nice
would the Japanese surrender if the new
but was
coming